JEREMY RENNER
Clint Barton is
one of the original six Avengers.
And because of this Hawkeye show,
we get to share together all of who
Clint Barton is in a very exciting way.
NEWS REPORTER
The Ronin vigilante was spotted...
CLINT BARTON
I'll be home for Christmas. I promise.
RHYS THOMAS
Hawkeye's compelling because there's
a sense that this ordinary guy is
just driven by this sense of duty
more than anything. He doesn't have
the protection of superpowers.
I find it interesting that you get to
join him where he essentially found
the peace that he's always wanted.
But you know that there's been this
price that's been paid.
CLINT BARTON
Ow.
BRAD WINDERBAUM
Clint has always been the human face
on the Avengers. He has all these
things about him that I think
parallel a lot of people's
true-life experiences.
And it's amazing what happens
when you let, you know,
actors like Jeremy Renner really have
the space to explore their character.
LILA BARTON
This the first Christmas
we've had together in years.
CLINT BARTON
I love you guys.
Come on, bud!
TRINH TRAN
Jeremy is very much into the truth
about the character. Having been
Clint Barton for the last ten years,
he knows this character inside out.
JEREMY RENNER
It's been an exciting,
exhilarating sort of ride.
And it's hard to quantify
what it's meant for me and my career.
But when I think of the MCU and my
experiences playing this character,
it becomes much more
of a personal journey.
And I'm excited to
see where it goes.